now let's check out our b our beautiful
view at the beautiful resorts world on
the las vegas strip we are in the best
spot we could possibly be on new year's
eve look at that it's beautiful out
there now the streets aren't filled up
yet but as we get closer to midnight on
the west coast it will fill up this is
definitely not a bad gig and of course
outside of resorts world is beautiful
but they actually let us inside and we
toured around and it's amazing check it
out
that video screen you just saw outside
100 000 square feet it's one of the
largest in the world would it fit in my
house i want to watch a movie on that
day that would be amazing but no i've
seen your apartment it's not fitting
this globe by the way i want to shake it
like a snow globe but i don't know if
you can because it's 50 feet in diameter
and i will tell you this it's one of the
most instagramable things in the hotel
that's all you had to say oh you ready
instagram yes speaking my language all
right let's get some pictures of you
know that hold on here we go
work it work it work oh yeah oh oh yeah
you know what you know what no i don't
know this is so hilarious
no oh my god you're such a great actor
we are actually at the gatsby cocktail
lounge right now i feel like i'm in the
roaring 20s because this was modeled
after the great gatsby you know i feel
like you should have a flapper's dress
i'm really sad i'm not wearing fringe
although i do have a flapper dance show
me please all right let's do it all
right stand up uh-huh it's like this
like that oh oh yeah you got it
i think i'm doing good i think i'm doing
it you know what would go good with this
dance what a drink hey bartender no no
no no wait what i have a secret what's
that they have a secret menu stop it
yeah seriously you just scan the qr code
hold on
[Music]
and uh champagne
all right i got to get you a drink
mickey here we go do i get a rubber
ducky in mine you want a ducky in there
oh i got you girl i got you here we go
little ducky right there drunky jackie
give me a little drink so i don't drink
as much as a year so i'm gonna i don't
want a ducky in mind i'm gonna let the
ducky float to be good cheers cheers to
gatsby's that's right
[Music]
oh the doghouse oh have you been talking
to my wife again no the sports part the
dog
i know you've been there many times
you'll feel right at home here all right
oh this dog house unlike yours has live
music yeah mine's just dark and a bunch
of sadness well there's lots of
brightness here lots of good things
happening oh my gosh let's go listen to
the live band oh yeah yeah
oh you can do that
wait
i should have bet that was gonna happen
can i get a hundred on the golden
knights winning the stanley cup and 200
on everyone having a happy new year
all right
all right i have the winning ticket
[Music]
i mean
i love this hotel look at the vogue from
uh the instagram snaps you are
instagram-worthy girl thank you and no
filters right now no filters that's
rarity nikki puts about 125 filters on
every photo that's on a good day michael
tomorrow morning 250.
put your money on that
[Laughter]
oh my god gatsby's as you can see is a
must-see it is so awesome you have to
check it out next time you're in vegas i
highly recommend the bubble bath with
the rubber duckies i have never wanted
to drink bath water till then it was so
good with a straw with a straw with a
straw now you are looking at the crowd
on the strip from dre's las vegas